over the course of six years I've
traveled across the UK uncovering
documents and speaking to families
people all connected by one thing the
drug primeros was used as a pregnancy
test but did it actually deform or even
lead to the death of children I'm
convinced and I will be to my dying day
that that this drug responsible for the
death of my child after decades with
little information a new government
commissioned reports into the effects of
this drug has now been released will it
provide the answers would you would you
recommend the use of this is a hormone
pregnancy test today you wouldn't no I
wouldn't
I've got a very shortened tongue part of
my gum missing
I have one eye that doesn't really work
at all there's obviously the arms then
my feet when I was born were very much
folded inwards I'm missing the big toe
on either sort so I have four toes on
each foot
[Music]
this is the copy of the medical records
that my mother has from the GP which
clearly shows prima das was prescribed
on the 26th we think that is of the
first 70 when Daniel was born his
parents suspected primatives was the
cause of his problems but medical
professionals told them his
malformations were just an unfortunate
fact of life only this year after
watching a Sky News documentary did
Daniel realize there was a whole group
of people who believed Prem dose may
have caused deformities to themselves or
their children people such as Mary Lyon
the chair of the Association for
children damaged by hormone pregnancy
tests her daughter was born with a
shortened limb Jeanette Dean's child
died shortly after her birth medical
records described her daughter as a
monster child it's incredibly powerful
to be sat in a room with that number of
people who've been so savagely affected
in their lives died this is fundamental
stuff for more than 40 years these
families have sought answers now the
long-awaited findings of a government
report have been published it finds
there is not the scientific evidence to
support a causal association despite
this warning on the packet in 1975 that
it could cause malformations the
evidence isn't strong enough to prove a
link but campaigners who met with the
MHRA today said the experts were asked
in the terms of reference to find
whether there was a possible link and
they haven't answered that question I
just think it's an absolute betrayal I
felt that their meeting we've just heard
was patronizing
it was designed basically to justify the
conclusions that they've made and the
conclusions they've made is actually on
a course a link which I just cannot
believe the terms of reference house
absolutely specific that what they're
looking for our should be looking for is
a possible association they did they say
whether they'd found a possible
Association no they've not looked for it
was there a possible association well
that word was chosen particularly
because we we entered the this group
with that very open minds about it we
didn't prejudge the issue we were
looking whether in effect was there not
an effect but with an open mind can you
answer that question was there possible
Association well we have from our
studies which have looked at all the
available evidence extensively thousands
and thousands of data from around the
country published and unpublished
information we did not demonstrate a
causal Association at a possible
Association the possible associations
when we started and we were open-minded
at whether there was any association or
not and then the result of our expert
group was not to find any decision are
you not willing to say whether there's a
possible association on medicine or is
always uncertainty and if any new
evidence was to arise we would certainly
be happy to look at that there might be
a reason why the report authors won't
answer that question if you look at the
document they released today it says
October 2017 and that's because it was
due to be released last month but they
pulled the press conference at the last
minute but we have a draft copy of the
original report now they may not have
changed the date but they have made some
significant changes inside in the
original copy they say the limitations
of the methodology of the time and the
relative scarcity of evidence means it's
not possible to reach a definitive
conclusion this sentence has been
removed
another thing that's disappeared from
draft to final copy is this graph it
shows that of human studies into hormone
pregnancy tests 8 out of 12 an
association between the use of the drug
and malformations the fact that the
report didn't have the right date on the
wrong month that clearly had been
adjusted from what had been presented
last month to
what is so so called the final draft
this month that does not give any
credence to the credibility of what's
written there in the body of the final
report human studies into specific
conditions and their relation to women
taking the drug appear to be concerning
of 15 into heart defects 11 favor an
association with the drug all five of
the studies on limb reduction do the
same but today's report authors say even
those showing a statistically
significant increased risk used outdated
methods and therefore could overstate
the Association but other experts
disagree actually it's quite possible
that the causality could be greater than
it is less I mean it could be at least
as possible if not more possible that
the Dudley that they calls the link is
greater than the weak link that those
studies demonstrate because of their
lack of capability to detect it on
animal studies the report authors have
chosen not to give consideration to the
most up-to-date study conducted this
year in Aberdeen on fish embryos because
they say it's yet to be peer reviewed
here the findings have been alarming and
there's some of the poems that we found
were things like enlarged hearts changes
to the yolk sac of the embryo the yolk
sac contains nutrients to allows an
embryo to grow twisted spines
compare this normal embryo to one where
the drug has been administered in early
stages of development a shortened tail
diminished yolk sac no eyes the earlier
the drugs given the more extensive the
damage and we also have fin defects so
you see the fins here away from the body
and you can see here that they're
damaged evolutionary the fins of the
fish gave rise to the limbs in us many
have waited decades for answers about
this drug and the peer review on the
aberdeen fish study is due in a matter
of days so it's odd that it's been
excluded especially considering today's
report uses 44 other non peer-reviewed
studies many of them were produced by
the manufacturer
makers of Prim das sheering now owned by
Bayer has released to the MHRA some of
the animal studies conducted just after
the drug was taken off the market in
1979 the compound was given to mice and
examination of embryos reported a
significant increase in visceral
malformations including the heart lung
and thorax wall at a high dose on this
the authors conclude the increase in
malformations in this study should be
considered drug-related I think some of
the animal studies that they refer to in
their report suggests that there is a
link clearly we need to do more work I
mean would you would you recommend the
use of this is a hormone pregnancy test
today you wouldn't no I wouldn't some of
the other animal studies don't appear to
show a link and regulators conclude that
overall they use outdated methods and
are inconclusive
I mean I think it's indisputable that
there's an association I might also say
MHRA and their predecessor organization
where the regulators and so I think
they're being defensive I'm not sure
they were the right people to put a
charge of a piece of work like this so
what does this report tell us about
regulatory failings the report authors
have explicitly decided not to examine
how the drug was regulated earlier this
year Sky News travelled to Berlin in
national archives we uncovered documents
showing whirring behavior by UK
regulators one of them warmed the
manufacturers that women who use prima
DOS had a five to one risk of giving
birth to a child with a malformation
but documents suggests the man working
for the Committee on safety of medicines
destroyed all the material on which his
investigation was based and he'd done
that to prevent individual claims being
based on his material it's something out
of spy story almost isn't it it's it's
the one can't really quite believe the
level of collusion and abuse of trust I
think many experts we've spoken to say
regulators should have been the key
focus of today's report ultimately what
we want to know is did the regulator do
a good job in looking after people at
the time and I don't know exactly how
that question might be asked I'd like it
if that question are answered in this
it's explicitly excluded in this report
shouldn't you be looking at the way it
was regulated our group was a group of
scientists and clinicians who have
particular expertise to look at the
evidence we were particularly not asked
to do and any review of the regulatory
issues around the time medicines has
moved on hugely in regulation and
medicines particularly we're now in a
very different environment that was not
our arena so nor can you say whether
there were any regulatory failings
we did not consider that we're a group
of scientists and experts who looked at
the signs you asked to draw lessons of
safety issues and communication isn't
that regulation this is a very
forward-looking report and we have made
at least 13 recommendations which we
have tasked the MHRA
our drug regulators to take forward but
campaigners say past mistakes should be
exposed people in authority did know
that there was a connection and chose to
not do anything about it and the a
measure has completely not looked at
them either so I don't honestly know
what the hell they spent all those weeks
and months doing because they did not
look at the evidence that was available
the pharmaceutical company Bayer notes
that a review by an independent expert
working group on hormone pregnancy tests
of the commission on human medicines has
found consistent with BAE's view based
on all available data that the
scientific evidence does not support a
causal association between the use of
hormone pregnancy tests such as
primitive and birth defects or
miscarriage since our documentary was
shown in Parliament earlier this year
the campaign group has swelled more than
100 MPs including cabinet and shadow
cabinet members have now joined a
cross-party group which Sky News
understands is demanding an
investigation into the regulator and
insisting the onus is now on the
government to get to the truth in the
body of this report there is evidence
that supports the claims of some of
these campaigners human studies and
animal studies that point towards a link
the working group says that they can't
find a causal Association but neither
can they say that this drug was safe for
more than 40 years they've looked for
answers and during that time the
manufacturer has always been given the
benefit of the doubt that just happened
again